it's just so fun ow
hello and welcome back to edible history
the show that makes history palatable
today we're taking a special look at
holiday history particularly the history
carved out by the one and only pumpkin
pie no holiday celebrates food quite
like thanksgiving but behind every
thanksgiving turkey there's the holidays
actual star pumpkin pie but i certainly
doubt the first pies came from
pre-mashed pumpkin bits in a can to
patch up my understanding of pumpkin pie
history i'm talking with paul friedman a
professor of history at yale and the
author of american cuisine and how it
got this way paul thank you so much for
being here today we're talking about
pumpkin pie and that's a little bit of a
tasty dish so how far back does the
history of the pumpkin pie go it goes
back to probably the 17th 18th century
pumpkin is a new world product so pretty
much after the discovery of the new
world and after the growth of traffic
back and forth it appears in european
recipes was the original pumpkin pie
more of a sweet dish or a savory dish it
wouldn't be as sweet as it is now
everything now is sweeter than in the
past the pumpkin pie of the colonial era
would not have been custardy or soft the
way we're used to the pumpkins in slices
and has it always been a holiday dish
you know for me when i think of pumpkin
pie i think of thanksgiving it's kind of
how i let myself know i need to start
christmas shopping uh same heat but uh
thanksgiving itself wasn't celebrated
nationally until it was proclaimed as a
holiday during the civil war after the
civil war there's a whole revival of
interest in the colonial era and instead
of it being when we were poor it becomes
kind of an object of fashion and
sentimentality so is there anything
about this recipe in particular you can
tell me so the recipe is from a family
named gardener well-off people in boston
the colonists didn't really like new
world products they kind of wanted to
live like europeans so the recipe that
we're going to use has apple slices as
well as pumpkin slices the final unusual
thing about it is that the recipe calls
for large quantities presumably there
are lots and lots of people who want to
eat these pies so the quantity is pretty
large paul i feel pretty well prepared
in my pursuit of pumpkin pie wow i'm
just impressed i got that out of my
mouth anyway we're going to start
cooking
we'll be using the recipe for a pumpkin
pie from mrs gardner's receipts from
1763. need the receipts she's got them
now we have to tread carefully here
though there's a recipe for eel pie on
the same page
[Music]
the first step is to pair and core a
quarter of a hundred apples aka 25 there
are less convenient ways to say that two
dozen plus one apples five less than 30
apples five more than 20 apples first
things first you're going to cut off the
little top you're going to cut off the
little bottom then you're going to try
and look cool by peeling an apple with
one hand like you're a pirate on a ship
if that doesn't work then you'll stop
[Music]
we have more apples right
[Applause]
now it's time to slice your apple
one apple down only six less than 30 to
go how about damn apples
now that you've got your quarter of a
hundred apples it's time to take your
12th of a dozen pumpkins and start
slicing
the first step is to deseed your pumpkin
for this we're gonna take off the top
yeah yeah
[Music]
did you guys hear that shink
then remove the top voila take a spoon
and scoop out all the seeds inside your
pumpkin there's nothing quite like the
smell that comes from deseeding a
pumpkin can i just say this looks
gorgeous
cut off the bottom
next we're going to cut our pumpkin into
quarters yeah baby
oh wow little this
[Music]
okay
you can take your smaller knife and
gently remove the last of your innards
now we cut them into smaller pieces
and now peel off the edges
one piece is done
now the rest 1 6 of 360 minutes later i
have now perfected my pumpkin peeling
performance i hope i never peel a
pumpkin again now that we've got
everything peeled and ready to rock
we're going to set this aside and get
started on making our dough
the recipe calls for a gallon of flour
so this is a gallon of flour first let's
add our salt
next we're going to be adding our very
cold butter it's important to keep your
butter cold because that's crucial in
the lamination process you're going to
blend it together using your hands to
just kind of marry the butter and the
flour okay that looks perfect now it's
time to add half of your water
beautiful make into a light paste with
cold water just stiff enough to work it
well up
[Music]
very distracting sensations
[Music]
next we're going to add the last of our
water
beautiful
[Music]
and give this dough a little more
kneading time and then we'll be ready to
roll also i'm gonna wash my hands
[Music]
now it's time to start rolling out our
dough so first things first
getting the dough out of the bowl
come on smooth as silk
i'm gonna put a little flour on my hands
i don't want them to be terribly sticky
the dough we're making here is a little
bit more like a puff pastry because
we're going to be adding a lot of butter
to it and folding it a bunch of times
beautiful now it's time to add our
butter we're going to put it on half of
our dough fold it over why do i always
explain things let me just show you add
our chili chili butter
beautiful next the recipe says that we
will be strewing a little flower upon it
from a dredging box or your hand
yes yes now the hard part we're gonna
lift up this half of our dough and
gently fold it over
our
butter yeah
add a little bit more flour this dredger
is really getting a lot of moments to
shine
then we're going to turn our dough
we roll it back out and then start the
whole process over and do it eight or
nine more times the recipe says that we
need to incorporate a pound and a half
of butter
so we'll be doing this for a minute
and that is the end
of rolling dough so
take your arms
and rest them
our next step is to slice our
beautifully laminated dough in half
because we will need both a top and a
bottom for our pie all right these are
all ready we're going to keep them cool
and finish our filling
[Music]
[Applause]
let's dough this we have our beautiful
giant dough and we need to put it in
this giant pot our basic goal is we want
to cover the whole bottom of this
beautiful cast iron pot without breaking
our dough let me lift this up
put this under oh oh no stay
stay
stay
our next step is to lay a half pound of
good clean sugar over the bottom of our
dish
good clean sugar
that's gonna be what makes it taste good
next we're gonna start layering in our
apples i will say i'm surprised by the
lack of spices in this recipe i
anticipated there'd be cinnamon clove
nutmeg so far it's just fruit and sugar
and a lot of butter now that you've got
your layer of apples it's time to add
your pumpkin sprinkle on some pumpkin
pieces
another sprinkling of sugar
and it's time for our next layer of
apples
[Music]
one last heaping helping the sugar and
we're ready to tuck this baby in now
it's time to take off the excess dough
so we're gonna cut around the edge and
set that dough aside remove
thank you thank you
beautiful ta-da
plop i'm going to go grab our next layer
of dough for the top
if you know an easier way to transport
dough let me know next we gently unfurl
hold on oh hello little dough baby we
gently
unroll our circle onto the top
almost perfect
there
awesome to seal on our top we're going
to pinch down all the excess we left on
the sides of the fruit when we were
talking to paul and he mentioned how
much pie they would make and it would
last and last and last i didn't get it
now i do
we're gonna cut some slits for air vents
the slits are for letting some of the
steam out plus they look really pretty
and give it a gentle egg wash for those
of you that don't know and have been too
scared to ask an egg wash is just a
beaten egg that you simply brush all
over your delicious thing you're making
frankly i'm pretty excited to try it i
mean i'm a big fan of apple pie and this
seems like we're making more of an apple
pie than a pumpkin pie that looks good
to me last but not least we're gonna
take this thing to bake
we are gonna take this thing to bake
okay a little help
[Music]
fresh from the oven and ready for some
lovin
i gotta tell you guys this pie smells
absolutely amazing not only does this
phi smell fantastic it looks beautiful
you know i always thought the pumpkin
pie was just one thing turns out pie's
the limit
now that we're done baking there's just
one last step the recipe says before you
send it to the table cut it open and put
in some good fresh butter it's like
treating a slice of pie like a piece of
toast delicious to insert our butter
we're gonna gently reopen our slices
hello hello my mouth is watering it
smells like a fresh baked pie we're
gonna gently peel back one corner of the
puff pastry and slide in our butter
beautiful effortless hard to believe
there's a quarter of a hundred apples in
here slightly slighty yummy yummy in my
tummy you can tell that the pie did bake
down quite a bit it's a lot shorter than
i remember but
smells even better all right
last but not least we got to set it
aside to cool and then we get to see if
this boston-based baked good actually
tastes good
okay it's the magic moment time to
figure out how to take out a slice of
this pie
let's do it there's so much butter in
this thing it's basically like a
non-stick surface now okay
now the moment of truth
[Music]
it's exceptionally hard to dig a pie out
of a deep
cast iron
pot
changing my approach
there we go
we
have
achieved
pie
this looks incredible what a beautiful
beautiful baked good i almost don't want
to eat it because it's so perfect
okay here we go moment of truth
history in the making history in the
baking
[Music]
this is delicious simple
yet effective it's like apple pie meets
pumpkin pie i was worried that the
texture variation would be too weird you
know like the squishy apple and the
chunky pumpkin but honestly
they balance out the puff pastry crust
what a dream come true it is very
different from the modern day pumpkin
pie i will say that the one thing i miss
is like the nutmeg the cinnamon i miss i
miss those spices that we so heavily
associate with fall it's definitely not
as sweet as pumpkin pie but frankly i
like that and i love the texture i mean
i love this pie
yum
thanks for watching this episode of
edible history let us know if you would
give this pie a try by leaving a comment
in the comments below seriously would
you make this for thanksgiving i
genuinely want to know
[Music]